all right let's go number two abc news
has this we'll play the video for you
uh it says cheers erupted in the streets
of buenos aires
argentina after the country's lower
house voted to pass a bill legalizing
abortion
a measure that will next go through the
senate so you can see here the
the crowds celebrating uh celebrating
the
the passage of this this bill just
[Music]
you see they're jumping mostly women
younger women in the crowd
they're jumping they're hugging they're
waving flags
they're in tears they're crying tears of
joy
and what are they no you see something
like this and you think
if you had no context what would you
think is going on here
maybe maybe there's you know
you can see this maybe if they're
watching their team won the super bowl
something like that but no this is this
is they're excited this is what they're
excited about they're excited they'll
have the opportunity now to kill their
babies they're in tears of joy
because now if they need to if they want
to they can kill their children
that's what they're weeping tears of joy
over
not you know no great shock here we know
this is the case with the pro-abortion
movement
except that what are we always told
we're always told that the pro-abortion
movement
is not the pro-abortion movement they're
not oh nobody's nobody's pro-abortion
nobody likes abortion
this is the line we get from
pro-abortion people all the time
no no one likes support no one no one
likes it no one's
oh or pro-choice not pro-abortion really
that's what you just saw there those
aren't people who
who like abortion
they're in tears of joy hugging in the
street
because they can now kill their children
they obviously want to be able to do
that
they are very pro that
now the pro-abortion movement is is
starting
to move a little bit away from that line
of saying
you still hear it a lot but they're
starting there's a movement now
very clearly to move away from that and
to stop saying oh no one's pro-abortion
and instead to say sure
but this is still among mostly among the
radicals on the pro-abortion side who
will come out and you know shout your
abortion they say yeah you know i like
abortion
i'm in favor of abortion it's not yet in
the mainstream of the pro-abortion
movement but i think it will go there
and really it's their only it's it's
it's a
it's their only strategy because the
problem all along it's like when they
used to say you never hear this anymore
but i can remember even growing up in
the 90s
um the big the line the the slogan the
thing they put on the poster boards and
the bumper stickers was
um safe legal and rare
and now they yeah they still want
abortion to be legal of course
and they still talk about the mythical
safe abortion which of course no
abortion could be safe because there's
always at least one person being killed
in it
and often more than one person being
well in fact in every case more than one
person being harmed
physically and emotionally in every
other sense but um
so but they still they still pretend so
they still say yeah safe legal
they don't talk about rare anymore
and the problem is when you say oh we
want abortion to be rare or when you say
oh
nobody really likes abortion the
follow-up question is why
well you say nobody likes it why don't
they like it
you say you want it to be rare why do
you want it to be rare
and the answer is because it's a it's a
it's a horrifying
horrible abominable thing
but if you admit that about abortion
then the whole house of cards comes
tumbling down and so their only choice
is to uh
is to pretend that it's it's uh that in
fact it's a positive it's a it's
something to celebrate
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future
content